Attention !
Une seule morsure de serpent et c'est la mort létale, immédiate.
T'inquiète...
J'ai toujours une arme sur moi.
Ça a marché ...
Bon on va pas moisir ici, alors voici le topo...
Un contact a réussi à me faire passer le matos de son fils
pour qu'on puisse élaborer un plan de sortie...
Lieutenant Patinson...
Ça m'étonnerait que nous arrivions à sortir de prison avec ce matériel...
À moins que...
Yesai !
Ah !
Monsieur le Président, je vous présente Maguire, mon meilleur conseiller.
Maguire, nous avons reçu un mail crypté très étrange.
Je vous en ai fait une copie.
Ça sent mauvais...
Je suis persuadé que c'est un coup des russes...
C'est triste, mais je vais devoir entrer en guerre contre ce pays.
Attendez...
Curri, curri, curri... Le déroulement.
Vitae, vital, la vie !
Le déroulement de la vie...
Ah ! C'est un curriculum vitae !
Un cv.
Aucun danger.
Bah du coup, on se fait un domac ?
Le trésor du Pharaon Abondophis.
Ouvrons-le !
Attends !
Qui nous dit qu'il n'est pas maudit ?
Regarde, il y a une inscription sur le co...
Mince, je n'y vois plus rien.
T'inquiète pas.
J'ai toujours mon porte-clé lumineux.
Bougez-plus un geste !
Vous croivez quoi ?
Que vous allez vous en sortir comme ça ?
La route s'arrête-là, Sanders.
Non, mon lieutenant.
Ce jeune agent fédéral a effectué une faute de français.
Vous ne pouvez pas dire "vous croivez que".
Vous devez dire "vous avez cru que".
Ou alors à l'imparfait "vous croyiez que".
Par voie de fait, votre ordre est irrecevable par mon collègue et moi-même.
Il a dit par voie de fait...
Messieurs.
Alors, c'est qui qu'on a gagné ?
Monsieur le Président, nous avons trouvé ce que vous nous avez demandé !
Si c'est bien ce que je pense Monsieur le Président, la Russie ne posera plus aucun problème !
Non ! Ne l'ouvrez surtout pas !
Putain de merde !
Les soviets ont enfin trouvé le moyen de nous niquer !
Attendez !
Regardez monsieur le Président, on a ici deux solutions...
L'une basique, l'autre acide.
À l'aide d'un indicateur coloré, on pourrait obtenir leur PH...
Et introduire une substance complémentaire qui nous permettrait d'annuler la réaction.
C'est vrai, mais ce n'est pas tout.
Vous voyez cette architecture électrique ?
Eh bien, c'est un circuit en série.
Si je place une résistance en dérivation...
On pourra affaiblir la sécurité et accéder au liquide.
J'ai justement un multimètre sous la main.
Si je place le curseur sur volt, je pourrais alors calculer la tension sans créer de court-circuit.
Et ce, en moins de trente secondes.
Ce qui nous permettra de désamorcer la bombe.
Incroyable.
Yesai !
Encore une fois grâce à votre talent...
C'est pas aujourd'hui qu'on va crever !